>> Tucker: THE FIRST THING YOU
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT MISSION GUN
GOVERNOR GRETCHEN WHITMER, A LOT
OF THINGS YOU SHOULD KNOW, THE
VERY FIRST IF SHE TAKES THE
CORONAVIRUS VERY SERIOUSLY.
THAT IS WHY SHE BANS PEOPLE IN
MICHIGAN FROM BUYING PAINT LAST
YEAR, THAT IS WHY SHE IS
NOW FORCING ALL 2-YEAR-OLDS IN
THE STATE TO WEAR MASKS.
IT IS ALSO WHY SHE WENT ON
TELEVISION RECENTLY TO WARN THE
PEOPLE OF MICHIGAN THAT THEY
SHOULD NOT TRAVEL TO FLORIDA
BECAUSE FLORIDA IS DANGEROUS.
>> WELL COME AT THE END OF THE
DAY, THIS IS MIKE TO COME DOWN
TO WHETHER OR NOT EVERYONE DOES
THEIR PART IN.
THAT IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING.
THIS VARIANT, THE VARIANT
GROWING QUICKLY IN MICHIGAN, WE
HAVE THE SECOND MOST OF IT, I
THINK AFTER FLORIDA, AT LEAST
THAT WAS THE LAST DATA I SAW.
MICHIGAN AND FLORIDA ARE NOT
NEXT TO EACH OTHER BUT THIS IS
THE TIME OF THE YEAR THAT
SNOWBIRDS COME HOME FROM
FLORIDA, WHERE PEOPLE ARE GOING
ON SPRING BREAK, AND ALL OF
THESE THINGS CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
SPREAD.
>> Tucker: IT'S DANGEROUS TO
GO TO FLORIDA.
EVERYONE HAS TO DO THEIR PART.
DON'T GO TO FLORIDA.
NOT LONG AFTER THAT, WE
LEARNED THAT GRETCHEN WHITMER
HAD GONE TO FLORIDA EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
NOW, WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG SHE
WAS IN FLORIDA.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE IN FLORIDA
SHE WENT.
NO ONE CAN FIND OUT BECAUSE HER
OFFICE IS CITING "SECURITY
CONCERNS."
CHARLIE DUFF WORKED AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AMONG TIME,
WON A PULITZER PRIZE, THEN WENT
TO MICHIGAN AND DOING EVEN
BETTER JOURNALIST.
CHARLIE DUFF, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE QUESTION,
WHY DON'T YOU COME AS A
MICHIGANDER COME HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW WHAT EXACTLY ARE GOVERNOR
WAS DOING IN FLORIDA?
>> BEATS ME.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, HERE ARE
SOME BREAKING NEWS.
I WAS TALKING TO THE FLORIDA
STATE POLICE, AND THEY DON'T
HAVE A RECORD OF HER CALLING UP
AND ASKING FOR SOME EXECUTIVE
SECURITY, WHICH IS NORMALLY THE
COURSE OF ACTION, SO SHE DIDN'T
WANT ANYBODY TO KNOW, SO MADAME
GOVERNOR, TELL US ALL, WHEN YOU
WENT, HOW WENT YOU WENT, AND
WHAT EXACTLY YOU RETURNED.
THAT WOULD BE NICE.
AND WHOSE CHECK DID YOU TAKE?
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE OTHER
QUESTION, HOW DID SHE GET THERE?
YOU CAN BE IN A POSITION WHERE
YOUR GOVERNOR IS A
SUPER-SPREADER AND HE WOULD NOT
KNOW.
YOU OBVIOUSLY HAVE ASKED THESE
QUESTIONS.
HELP OTHERS HAVE ASKED.
TELL US WHAT KIND OF ANSWER YOU
HAVE RECEIVED FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
>> HERE IS THE THING, NOT ONLY
DO I FIND OUT SHE WENT, I FOUND
OUT HER HEALTH DIRECTOR WENT
DOWN TO MARGARITAVILLE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PANDEMIC, NOT
FULLY VACCINATED, NOR WAS THE
GOVERNOR.
I ASKED THE QUESTIONS, I DO THE
GENTLEMANLY, JOURNALISTIC THING,
AND I WAIT.
AND WHILE I'M WAITING, THEY LEAK
IT TO A FRIENDLY OUTLET THAT
PUTS ICING ON THE CAKE AND A
COUPLE OF ROSETTES, YOU KNOW,
CANDY CANES, SO IT ALL COMES OUT
SWEET.
I WANT THE ANSWERS.
SHE SAID, HER PEOPLE SAID YOU
CAN'T GET THAT ANSWER BECAUSE
ONGOING THREATS.
WELL, IF THERE WAS ONGOING
THREATS, WHY DIDN'T YOU CALL THE
STATE TROOPERS IN FLORIDA?
>> Tucker: THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION!
AND BY THE WAY, THIS IS A TRIP
THAT HAS ALREADY HAPPENED, SO
HOW WOULD IT BE A THREAT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S SECURITY TO TELL US
SOMETHING THAT SHE HAS ALREADY
DONE?
>> HELLO, THIS IS THE STATE I AM
LIVING IN, TUCKER.
AND AGAIN, LOOK, OKAY, YOU SAY
YOUR DAD IS SICK.
THAT'S FINE, BUT A SERVANT
LEADER EATS LAST, LEAVES THE
BURNING BUILDING LAST, AND LEADS
BY EXAMPLE.
YOU DON'T GO SEE YOUR DAD, JUST
LIKE I COULDN'T SEE MY DYING
BROTHER THREE WEEKS AGO DRAW HIS
LAST BREATH, BECAUSE THAT IS
WHAT WE DO.
I THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
BUT I'M OF US DO, AND SOME OF US
DON'T.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT'S AN
AWFUL STORY.
FIRST OF ALL, I'M SORRY, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
THE STATEMENT HAS REGULATIONS
THAT YOU CAN'T SEE YOUR BROTHER
WHEN HE DIES, BUT YOUR GOVERNOR
IN FLORIDA PROBABLY ON A PRIVATE
PLANE BECAUSE SHE WANTS TO SEE
HER DAD.
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, WHEN SHE
SAYS -- SHE SAID A COUPLE WEEKS
EARLIER, ABOUT TEN DAYS BEFORE
SHE GOT CAUGHT OUT, THAT SHE
HASN'T LEFT IN 14 MONTHS.
HER LAST TRIP WAS TO ISRAEL.
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
RED FLAG, BECAUSE EVERYBODY
KNOWS SHE WENT TO THE
INAUGURATION.
HE WENT TO SEE YOUR DAD.
WE WERE LOCKED DOWN BY HER LAST
APRIL.
WE COULDN'T GO TO OUR FISHING
SHACK, COULDN'T GO-BETWEEN.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE LIVING WITH.
JUST BE HONEST, BE STRAIGHT, AND
WHEN PEOPLE ARE TOLD IT STRAIGHT
AND CLEAR, THEY START TO REBEL.
SO HERE'S WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
IT'S OVER.
NOBODY'S LISTENING.
THIS THING IS GOING TO SPREAD.
IT'S NOT KILLING CHILDREN.
IT STILL ATTACKING THE OLD AND
THE OBESE, AND SHE HAS LOST
CONTROL OF THE STATE.
THAT'S A FACT.
>> Tucker: EXACTLY, BECAUSE
SHE DOESN'T DESERVE CONTROL OF
THE STATE.
CHARLIE LIVED OFF, THANK YOU FOR
ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS AND FOR
YOUR PERSISTENCE.
>> BY THE WAY, BRO, I'M GOING TO
GET AN ANSWER ON MY LAWSUIT WITH
THOSE NURSING HOME SOON, AND